il y a des choses dont je ne vous ai
jamais parlé vous souvenez toutes ces
vidéos d'anecdotes qu'on a fait bla bla
bla et ben on n'a pas fait pour d'autres
moments pourquoi pas ce que j'ai raconté
tellement d'anecdotes que j'avais plus
rien à raconter mais vous savez on rit
on grandit on vit des choses et parfois
on se souvient de quelques trucs bon
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter trois
anecdotes de quand j'étais petit il ya
d'ailleurs l'une de ces anecdotes ou
aujourd'hui encore mes parents n'ont
jamais su la vérité qui vont l'apprendre
en regardant cette vidéo comme vous
alors papa maman d'avant solesmes
étonnamment on va commencer avec une
première très rapide très concise juste
pour montrer à quel point quand on est
plus jeune on est très naïf et on pense
être trop mal
alors vous le savez quand j'étais petit
j'étais un gros fan des écrans des jeux
vidéo j'avais la ps1 jouer à tekken et
fif avec mon frère plus tard j'ai eu la
gamecube etc
mais avant tout ça ça a commencé par des
jeux sur l'ordinateur
moi je suis un vrai mois steam pc depuis
le plus jeune âge
en gros pendant très longtemps mon frère
avait le droit d'aller sur l'ordinateur
mais pas moi donc je le regardais jouer
au loin je crois qu'ils jouent à quake
unreal tournament à l'époque et moi je
pouvais pas y jouer alors j'étais jaloux
mon plus jeune âge grande jalousie et
donc j'ai commencé à entamer un travail
psychologique auprès de mon père ou
petit à petit jeu les préparer à me dire
oui pour que je puisse jouer sur son
ordinateur portable ça a duré des mois
et des mois donc ces détails tout court
par exemple ton frère et sur l'ordi ton
père est dans le canal
et toi tu passes à côté de ton frère en
disant oh la la il a l'air bien ce jeu
et tu regardes ton père % qui va te
proposait d'y jouer mais pas du tout il
te dis juste d'aller faire tes devoirs
c'est chaud mais après plusieurs mois on
est au le samedi matin on passe les
week-ends chez mon père et pour la
millième fois je passe devant mon frère
qui est en train de jouer sur l'ordi et
jeudi à haute voix j'espère un jour que
mes parents sont des parents modèles m
laisseront pourquoi pas jouer à
l'ordinateur mais bon après je veux
accuser personne dans cette pièce
surtout pas le monsieur au gros ventre
la base sur le canapé et là mon père me
regarde plus canapé et me dit allez cet
aprèm
tu pourras faire de trois parties à bala
ont applaudis timidement l'après midi
mon père se casse de chez moi mon frère
se casse de chez moi et je suis tout
seul sur cet ordinateur à pouvoir jouer
à eux de reals tournament pour la
première fois de ma vie
et les mecs vous rendez compte je suis
sûr vous souvenez même pas de votre
première partie de jeu vidéo j'avais 7 8
ans je contextualise j'étais vraiment
très très jeune je n'avais rien à faire
sur cet ordinateur quoi merci papa
c'était ma toute première partie sur un
fps mec du coup j'étais nul très nul je
joue je meurs je meurs je meurs je
remuais et je commence à m'énerver à
être pas bien je découvre ce que c'est
que la rage sur un jeu vidéo à ce moment
là plus ou moins j'ai le plaisir et plus
je me dis que je suis nul à côté des
autres du coup mon ego d'enfants de 8
ans moi qui croyais être le plus malin
et plus et la planète bas mon ego
explose et la mecque je craque
complètement j'oublie tout tout et je
frappe comme ça à multiples reprises le
clavier de l'ordinateur et là hop une
petite touche qui s'en va au fil des
coups hop deuxième up non lucas pas un
troisième quand même troisième la jarre
est comme ça je comprends les esprits et
c'est précisément à ce moment là de ma
vie où j'ai compris que les actes
avaient des conséquences à ce moment là
et je vois les trois touches comme ça
qu'ils ne sont pas là où elle devrait
être
elles sont par terre et là je me dis bah
je suis mort en fait je suis foutu mon
père va rentrer il va voir les touches
détacher il va me soulever tout de suite
vous avez tous deux que cette situation
où tu sais que tu as fait une grosse
connerie étudie comment je maquille
comment je fais pour camoufler ça et
qu'on ne me repère jamais et là hop
grosse idée de génie j'ai 8 ans je suis
un petit fils où je suis un ouf
qu'est ce que je fais je remets les
touches à leur place ferme l'ordinateur
et je vais dans mon lit si tout ça c'est
mon plan je me suis vraiment dit bah
quoi il va ouvrir le pc du real et
touche au bon endroit et puis quand lui
il va taper elles vont partir et ce sera
sa faute a dit c'est pas la mienne mon
père quand il va le soir chic et ses
mails etc
il ouvre le pc les touches partent
immédiatement c'est bon immédiatement je
n'ai pas pu jouer à des jeux vidéo sur
son pc pendant des années vous comprenez
ça d amener voilà c'est une chute pas au
fait c'est une mise en bouche la
prochaine j'ai dû résister à la beauté
parce que je m'en voulais ce que j'ai
fait aujourd'hui je pense que je peux le
raconte j'avais 12 ans donc la soif
d'aventuré de frissons d'angoissé de
tout ça quoi et avec mes potes on repère
un camp dans lequel dorment des forains
y avait une fête foraine pas loin de ma
ville et bref non trouve le camp où il
loge et il se repose et il y a
ah ben voilà il était là il était un
endroit vraiment il faisait leur vif un
nom auprès des forains quoi joseph et je
sais pas pourquoi on trouvait ça genre
trop stylé genre trop bad boys d'aller
les voir et de les faire chier un peu
c'est débile c'est lui et on va aller
les voir et faire du bruit on est détail
c'est de claquer au lit ça c'est un truc
de gamin tu crois trop que c'est
incroyable et antisystème était un
rebelle
alors c'était juste un petit con qui
feraient mieux de casser les touches du
pc portable de son père tu vois vraiment
en fait les caravanes étaient sur un
espace derrière une butte donc quand tu
montais au delà but tu avais une vue sur
le camp on s'amuse toutes les semaines à
aller en haut de la butte à observer à
les voir et c est un jour on observe et
on est observée aussi en bas de la butte
se trouvent deux enfants je me souviens
très bien en train de faire des trucs
avec un couteau papillon il le maîtriser
mon gars il avait 9 ans ok mais c'était
très très beau de les voir faire ça nous
ça nous met la pression on a intimidé et
on se dit ils ont trois ans moins
que nous et ils sont plus bad boys et
joue avec des couteaux papillon whaou en
vrai on aurait voulu être ces enfants là
mais on n'était pas du tout ces
enfants-là bref on revient la semaine
d'après et moi avec moi je prends un
ballon de foot j'ai honte mais c'est
vrai ça joue écolo etc je découvre un
peu l'effet de la testostérone je me
dirais je suis trop en mal à fanons
lucas et dans dix ans tu ne le seras
toujours pas ce n'est pas grave ça ne va
pas t'empêcher de bien dormir de faire
des trucs cool et de plaire à des gens
c'est pas grave mais tout ça personne ne
l'avait dit ok je pose ce ballon en cuir
sur la butte et je tire de toutes mes
forces
en direction des caravanes en contrebas
et là on entend un bruit de verre qui se
casse en gros il a probablement rebondi
et il est allé dans une vitre et ça a
pété une vie tree ce que c'est bon pour
vous la débilité de ses enfants
moi et mes potes on se chie dessus et on
va se cacher à proximité de la butte
pour ou à l'occasion on va se cacher à
proximité voir si quelqu'un sort de
l'endroit plutôt que de rentrer
directement chez nous c'est débile et au
bout de deux minutes
il ya un mec qui sort du camp un forain
ultra vénère très grand très musclé qui
fait ce geste
ce geste veut dire si je vois l'élément
qui a fait ça je l'unique sa mère
immédiatement ça on était petit mais on
l'a très vite compris on s'apprête à
aller chercher nos trottinette et
cartables qu'on avait mis dans un chemin
pas loin de là parce qu'en fait on a
fini deux heures plus tôt mais on
n'avait pas dit à nos parents donc on
avait foncé là bas pour faire sa fin
tout dit débile je vous le dis j'ai pas
bon du tout et qu'on est là on se dit
attentes autant si on va dans le chemin
prendre nos affaires en aller loin et
que par malheur le gars est là et a
trouvé nos affaires ont ça a pris un
sandwich parce que c'est sûr il a
prévenu tous ses sauts s'ils nous
cherchent tous à l'heure actuelle on est
les mecs les plus recherchés de la ville
c'est sûr et donc on décide de faire
tout le tour pour arriver de l'autre
côté du chemin côté par lequel on était
arrivée initialement lorsqu'on a posé
nos affaires on marche donc sur ce
chemin en se disant on est trop
malin joggeuse dira t on et des boues
trou du cul ouais on est vrai beaucoup
on tombe nez à nez avec lui le mec
toujours comme ça il était là avec nos
affaires dans les mains la yam 10 blancs
un petit moment de malaise est là le mec
lachenaud à faire et on tape le sprint
de notre vie dans la direction opposée
mais quand je dis le sprint de ma vie
c'est qu'on a couru deux kilomètres à
pleine vitesse sans s'arrêter et donc je
rentrais ma mère me dit va lui qu'à ta
pâte à trottinette et ton cartable et je
n'avais pas quoi je pouvais pas inventer
une excuse cgt mort l'a donc j'explique
à ma mère comme les a volés m dit
comment ça entre les a volés des gens
doivent chose à que de voler ton
cartable est à trottinette moisissent
l'entretien usé de ouf et où ai je dit
non mais à voler c'est abusé il ya des
voleurs maman dans cette ville c'est
scandaleux
le mec qui s'enfonce dans son mensonge
quoi ma mère ne sait toujours pas la
vérité aujourd'hui elle sait toujours
pas quand j'ai tiré avec un ballon
étoile s'est toujours pas et donc je
obligé de lui avouer une partie de la
vérité à savoir l'opus du on sort des
cours deux heures plus tôt et on va
là-bas pour observer les forains et en
repartant nos affaires ont disparu et on
suppose que c'est eux c'est terrible de
s'enfoncer dans le mensonge comme ça
c'est assume mec t'as fait de la merde
assume et là ma mère se chauffent elle
dit à mon beau-père et ben on va aller
récupérer des affaires on prend la
voiture et on prend la route en
direction de là où il ya les fous rires
moi dans la voiture je me dis je suis
mort déjà parce qu'en arrivant le mec
est sortie du camp il sera là et il va
me dire frérot je suis pas débile
t'attirer au ballon sur notre campement
étape était une vite donc c'est là tu
vas te l'apprendre et en plus parce que
ma mère va apprendre que tout ça c'est
ma faute
alors robert lieb là-bas et mouvaux
perdre descend de la voiture il vaut
mieux
l'endroit est dédié vous n'avez pas vu
les cartables et les trottinettes on
dirait le début d'un mauvais faits
divers et les gens en face répond très
gentiment banda le casse toi quoi il est
21h on est au mois de janvier était pas
autre chose à là mon beau père
revient on rentre à la maison et c'est
la fin de l'histoire jusqu'à une semaine
plus tard ou mon beau-père roulant sur
la route qui longe l'endroit où il ya
les fous voit au loin quelque chose qui
brille dans un champ et il se trouve que
c'était notre hôte ynet
alors tout est bien qui finit bien et
j'ai pu avoir un nouveau cartable
beaucoup plus beau que l'ancien c'est
une fin injuste vu ce que je méritais
alors j'aimerais présenter mes excuses à
ces gens
s'il y en a qui regarde cette vidéo les
gars désolé j'étais débit et bien ouej à
celui qui allait à l'école avec mon gars
table parce qu'il était plus beau que le
tien
c'était la dernière grosse connerie de
ma vie alors de ceux qui regardent cette
vidéo et qu'on use 12 ans ne fait pas ça
c'est idiot
bref il est un bassin à la dernière
anecdote qui à sa place
un peu dans un thread horreur mais un
trader très gentil vraiment très gentils
vous souvenez dans une vidéo anecdote je
vous ai raconté la fois où j'étais en
colonie où j'ai fait le mur pour aller
dans le dortoir des filles avec des
potes et où j'avais gâcher tentative
dans mes potes d'embrasser la fille
qu'il aimait et bien écouté lors de
cette même colonie il s'est passé l'un
des trucs les plus flippants de toute ma
vie vous allez avoir très peur au début
et quand je vais dire la chute vous
allez quitter la vidéo tellement c'est
pas ouf assez juste à passer la barres
des excuses et moi on se retrouve dans 5
minutes vous me direz si j'avais alors
c'était une colonie je sais plus haut en
france dans un centre équestre
ma mère m'avait inscrit parce que
j'adorais les animaux et aussi parce
qu'elle voulait se débarrasser de moi
pendant deux semaines tous les ans et du
coup j'y suis allé trois années de suite
et c'était génial et cette année là
c'était la dernière c'est à dire que
tout le monde savait que l'année d'après
il n'allait pas y retourner et
l'anecdote que je vais vous raconter se
passe la dernière nuit de la dernière
année où on a fait cette colonie avec
les gens ce centre équestre était
entouré de champs puis de forêt c'est à
dire que la nuit si tu sortais tu te
fais chier dessus mec
ok mais ce soir-là de cette année là on
s'est dit les gars c'est notre chance on
en parle depuis trois ans venez on va
dans la forêt cette nuit mes gars
dangereux à ne surtout pas faire quand à
12 ans il est minuit on sait que les
animateurs sont soit en train de se
bourrer la gueule dans leur dortoir qui
sont très loin des nôtres soient y
dorment et on décide de partir par la
fenêtre de notre chambre
sachez qu'à l'époque rester éveillés
jusqu'à minuit pour nous c'était un truc
de malade déjà déjà on était dehors à la
loi juste parce qu'on est éveillé
jusqu'à minuit donc on sort de la
chambre et là la première étape c'est de
traverser le champ on traverse le champ
on arrive à l'entrée de la forêt et
lamont
la c5 même à 23 ans je me retrouve au
même endroit je me chie dessus la forêt
elle est épaisse la lumière de la lune l
éclair à peine mais on est malin on a
emmené une lampe torche
quelle erreur dès le début il ya une
erreur et on s'enfonce dans la forêt on
march 10 15 minutes
et là on tombe sur un groupe d'arbres on
s'assoit chacun au pied d'un arbre
chacun notre tour on se passe la lampe
torche on éclaire notre visage et on
raconte une histoire qui fait peur genre
là à 23 ans si on faisait ça je
raconterai exactement cette histoire là
je vous chers et je me souviens la lampe
torche arrivent entre les mains d'un
pote qui s'appelait arnaud arnaud big up
a toi tu regarde cette vidéo frérot ça
fait dix ans mais je me suis toute ma
vie je suis pas bien là arnaud il
commence à raconter son histoire et
après trois quatre phrases on entend une
respiration on se regarde tous les
quatre et on constate tous le même
problème la respiration c'est celle
d'aucun nous quatre puisqu'elle provient
d'un endroit qu'est qu'à cet endroit là
il n'y a aucun d'entre nous et cette
situation elle durera le monde 10
secondes
ayant ressenti elles durent 10 jours
arnaud toujours le visage éclairé est un
la lampe torche et là on attend 30
secondes dans le noir complet
je sais ce que vous dites vous dites
mais pourquoi vous n'avez pas éclairer
là d'où venait la respiration pour voir
ce que c'était et ben écoutez la réponse
est simple on ne voulait pas voir ce que
c'était on voulait devenir invisible
cette fois voulait devenir un tronc
d'arbre tous et le bruit de respiration
se rapproche de nous on n'entendait pas
en plus de ça et là arnaud rallume la
langue est dit
qu'aurait on se lève et je tape le
deuxième plus grosse prime de ma vie le
premier étant celui en revenant du camp
des formes
il ya un des gars du groupe pendant
concours qui se mange une racine d'arbre
et qui tombe vous voyez dans les films
les héros il s'arrête et court vers le
gac est tombé il le relève dans la vraie
vie tout le monde s'en bat les couilles
personne ne s'est arrêté bon d'accord je
vais courir mon gars c'est yao a là on
te souhaite une belle mort
on arrive dans le champ qui était quand
même assez épais il faisait peut-être
sept minutes de marche pour traverser
atteindre la forêt on court au concours
et pendant que je cours je me retourne
et je vois les céréales qui était très
grand ces cartes et vous savez je vois
le truc se rapprocher parce qu'ils
s'écartent comme ça et là je comprends
qu'on ait poursuivi
alors je cours encore plus vite on
arrive devant la chambre on saute me
souviens par la fenêtre et arnaud c'est
vraiment le héros de l'histoire c'est le
gars qui en arrivant il n'a pas sauté
dedans il a dit allait dépêcher vous
rentrez allez allez moi je rentre je
t'ai première rentrée siropcool lucas
hochart c'est donc là on est à proximité
du centre dont quelle lumière
donc ils voient ce que c'est qu'ils me
suivent mais nous on est dans la chambre
on ne voit pas les bruits de pas
s'arrête
arnaud reste figée ça dure plusieurs
secondes et d'un coup il saute à
l'intérieur la chambre et il ferme la
fenêtre
donc là il ya un gros silence on réalise
tout ce que ça s'est pas passé comme on
voulait évidemment et arnaud nous dit
les amis on vient de se faire poursuivre
par un de sanglier et c'est lui
qu'on avait entendu respire et fort
qu'on avait entendu marchés etc et il
nous a suivis jusqu'au centre et du coup
on s'en est sorti lundi qu'elle mais
voila voila c'est la chute à si vous
vous êtes déçu ah ah bah désolé à
brighton psychopathe qui vivaient dans
la forêt pas du tout c'est dans les
films ça comme le mec qui se prend la
racine et qui tombe dans la lah pour
coup ça ça arrive vraiment je comprends
alors petit rappel à son ailier c'est
une bête qui fait en moyenne 200 kg que
ça peut même faire jusqu'à 300 dans des
cas vraiment incroyable au trot il court
à 20 km/heure mais quand ils sprit
il atteint les 70 km 1 donc si ce sont
liés avait voulu nous but et ils nous
auraient buté
c'est bon pour vous pour la petite
anecdote du coup on avait raconté sa
lendemain au moniteur qu'ils s'en
foutaient puisque c'était la fin de la
colonne donc les allez pas nous
embrouiller sachant qu'on n'est plus
jamais revenir et l'un des moniteurs en
fait vivait dans une maison au milieu de
la forêt enfin quand il n'était pas au
travail à savoir en train de nous
surveiller travail qui faisait bien
pardon bref du coup il connaissait
beaucoup les animaux etc et nous a
expliqué qu'on avait sûrement pénétrer
sur le territoire d'une meute ou d'un ou
d'une sangle et qui peut-être même
protéger ses petits elle nous a chassés
parce qu'elle avait peur de nous en
faire taire sa santé en danger menacée
elle ou ses petits schémas et c'est
comme ça que j'ai eu la folie des forêts
ou écoutez c'était probablement la
dernière vidéo anecdotes de ma jeunesse
de la chaîne
j'espère que vous a plu alors j'aime
bien faire sans ce moment dans les
vidéos là c'est mon délire un peu mais 4
et sur des forums plus chaud pour que la
dans les commentaires cette vidéo vous
racontiez chacun raconte une énorme
connerie qu'il a fait quand il était
petit ou un truc vraiment flippant qu'il
a vécu là où l'autre vous choisissez
mais je veux des commentaires ce soit ça
comme ça on a envie de les lire et c'est
cool
plutôt que juste d'essayer d'avoir des
like en design black a été fait 20 fois
avant qu'est ce que je fais ça pour
avoir l'espace commentaires coûte cette
vidéo est ce que je fais ça pour avoir
des commentaires est peut-être un
meilleur référencement ou est ce que je
fais ça pour être sûr que j'étais pas
l'enfant le plus con de la planète
franchement je sais pas je vous dis à
bientôt et n'oubliez pas d'aller pas
titiller les sangliers c'est la finale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
été
[Applaudissements]